We will now go through a very
simple example, in which we
just get to use the formulas
that we have available.
The Poisson process is a pretty
good model of email arrivals
at least during a
limited part of the day.
For example, during
daytime, emails
may be arriving as a Poisson
crosses with a certain rate.
But then during
night time, they may
be arriving as a Poisson
process with a different rate.
Nevertheless, the
assumption that we will make
is that, at least
for this problem,
that emails arrive
as a Poisson process
with a fixed rate of
five messages per hour.
What is the mean
and the variance
of the number of emails
received during a day?
Well, we have formulas for
the mean and the variance.
And in this problem, we
have a lambda equal to 5,
and tau consists of 24 hours.
So the answer is 5 times 24.
And this answer applies to both
of the mean and the variance,
because for the Poisson random
variable, these are the same.
What is the
probability that we get
one new message
in the next hour?
This has to do with the PMF
of the number of arrivals
during the next
hour, and that PMF
is given by the
Poisson probabilities.
We're asking for the
probability of one new message,
so that k is equal to
1, in the next hour,
so that tau is equal to 1.
So we're looking for
this expression here.
And using also that
lambda is equal to 5,
we enter those numbers
into this formula.
And what we obtained is
5 times e to the minus 5.
Finally, what is the
probability that during each
of the next three hours,
you'll obtain two messages.
So this is an event
which is actually
the intersection
of three events,
the event of two
messages in this hour,
two messages in this hour,
and two messages in that hour.
For the Poisson process, we
have assumed that different time
intervals are independent
of each other.
So what we need to
do is to multiply
the probability of two
messages in this hour
with the probability of
two messages in that hour,
and the probability of two
messages in that power.
On the other hand, for
each one of the hours,
the probability's
going to be the same,
so it's enough to take the
probability of two messages
during this hour, which is in
our notation this quantity,
and multiply it with
itself three times,
so we get the third
power of this.
Now this expression is
equal to the following.
Lambda times tau is 5.
k is equal to 2, so
we get 5 squared.
Then we have an e
to the minus 5 term.
And k is equal to 2,
so we're dividing by 2.
And we take the
third power of this.